divide simplifica la respuesta y
escríbela como número mixto
como tenemos una división de números
mixtos lo primero que vamos a querer
hacer es pasarlos a fracciones impropias
empecemos con dos enteros un cuarto en
el denominador seguiremos teniendo un 4
y en el numerador que tendremos a ver 2
es lo mismo que ocho cuartos ocho
cuartos y un cuarto hacen nueve cuartos
otra manera de verlo es hacer 4 x 2 819
y esta es otra forma de obtener un 9
entonces 2 enteros un cuarto es lo mismo
que 9 cuartos ahora vamos con un entero
tres cuartos y hagamos exactamente el
mismo proceso en el numerador tendremos
4 por 14 + 3
siete cuartos entonces teníamos dos
enteros un cuarto entre un entero tres
cuartos que es lo mismo que nueve
cuartos entre siete cuartos y ya hemos
visto que dividir entre una fracción es
lo mismo que multiplicar por el
recíproco de esa fracción entonces esto
es lo mismo que nueve cuartos por el
recíproco de siete cuartos pero el
recíproco de siete cuartos es lo mismo
que invertir el siete por el 4
entonces nos queda 4 séptimos fíjate
bien que pasamos de una división a una
multiplicación de fracciones entonces ya
solamente nos queda multiplicar podemos
hacerlo de una manera no muy inteligente
es decir podemos hacer 9 por 4 que es 36
entre 7 por 4 28 y luego lo tendríamos
que simplificar pero podemos simplificar
desde antes
porque en esta parte de aquí tenemos un
4 en el numerador y un 4 en el
denominador entonces dividamos 4 entre 4
da una y cuatro entre 4 a 1 y se
cancelan por lo que nos queda 9 x 19
entre 7 x 1
entonces tenemos 9 séptimos pero esto es
una fracción impropia y nos habían
pedido que diéramos la respuesta como un
número mixto entonces hace falta
convertir esta fracción impropia en
número mixto para ello debemos de
preguntarnos cuántas veces cabe el 7 en
el 9 pues resulta que el 7 cabe una vez
en el 9 una vez
y sobran dos entonces tenemos dos
séptimos uno entero dos séptimos y ya
acabamos